florida governor ron desantis is now
selling merch on his campaign website
that says don't fouchy my florida which
is very effective merchandise
because all sensible people think that
dr fauci is a big jerk who should be
exiled to saint helena
but it also reveals that that governor
desantis is seeing where the real divide
is in america the real divide in america
right now
is not geographic it's not don't
california my texas or whatever it's not
really that
people leave in california to go to
texas generally are extremely
conservative
it's not partisan by the way if you look
at the federal government
very often it's republicans and
democrats pushing the same stuff that
the majority of americans
really do not support and which actually
harms the interests of a lot of
americans
the real divide right now in the united
states
is between the people and the
technocratic
ruling elite which is symbolized and led
by dr fauci who is
the most powerful politician in america
that ruling elite right now
is as we're seeing with increasing news
reports poisoning people
with drugs censoring people from getting
their views out there
and in some cases even prosecuting
americans by a double standard
that would make the founding fathers
roll in their graves i'm michael knowles
it's the michael mueller show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from christoph
rodriguez who says democrats flying to
dc
i guess referring to the texas democrats
flying to dc is actually the sequel to
snakes on a plane that's true and i have
had it with these
i won't say this is a family show i
won't i won't say the entire line
i actually saw ron desantis last night i
was at an event here in the great state
of florida
and i saw governor desantis and he's
very impressive you know he's obviously
running for president
he's going to need to be vetted there's
going to be a primary campaign he's
going to have to get through a
governor's race first for reelection
but he's a very impressive guy and all i
know is regardless of
the governor himself whoever becomes
the republican nominee in 2024 needs to
channel what ron desantis is channeling
right now
period there there that is that is the
zeitgeist
that is the spirit of what is going on
right now
dr fauci is the symbol
and the actual politician that is
representing
so much that has gone rotten in our
country
and by the way dr fauci is insistent
after all
the power grabs he's had after all the
demands he's made of you wear the mask
take the vex
lock yourself up don't have christmas
don't have
thanksgiving don't shut up sheep all the
demands he's made
he now wants your three-year-old child
to wear those filthy cloth masks now
we're a year and a half past 15 days to
slow this bread
he wants your little kid to wear those
masks he said there is no doubt
that that's the right thing to do the
children who are not
able to get vaccinated because of their
age
should follow their parents should
follow with them the guidelines
of the cdc that unvaccinated children of
a certain age greater than two years old
should be wearing
masks no doubt about that that's the way
to protect them from getting infected
because if they do
they can then spread the infection to
someone else
so the cdc guidelines for unvaccinated
people including children
are not changed at all
you see the three-year-olds who even dr
fauci i think is tacitly admitting here
face an infinitesimally small risk of
any serious complication from covid
the three-year-olds you see if they
don't wear the masks which
dr fauci told us at the very beginning
of the pandemic are not effective
at preventing the spread of a virus and
then he contradicted himself later on
and there have been studies that have
raised a lot of questions about this
which we've read on this show even
though big tech doesn't want us to
what dr fauci is saying is even if the
three-year-olds don't face a great risk
from covet
they can spread it if they don't wear
the mask now you might be saying michael
all the other people are vaccinated so
if you're in a demographic
that is at very high risk of covid
presumably you are vaccinated at this
point the vaccines have been out for a
very long time if you're not vaccinated
there's a very specific reason why it's
very intentional
why you would not be so if the vaccines
work then the three-year-old doesn't
need to wear the mask
but the vaccines i guess don't work at
preventing the spread
so therefore the three-year-olds need to
wear the mask but no the vaccines do
work which is why you have to get it
which is why
anyone 12 and up needs to get and
hopefully children younger than that
according to the public health
administration it's it's whim
it's caprice it's changing every day
much like political correctness actually
the public health
regime which is just sort of the most
noticeable aspect of the broader
progressive technocratic regime
is less about the rules themselves
whatever
the rules are changing all the time it's
less about that and it's more about the
imposition of the rules the very fact
that the dr faucis of our technocratic
elite can just
get you to do whatever they want you to
do and they can say don't go to church
but you can go to a casino and you can
go to a liquor store but you can't go to
thanksgiving and they can just
they can just make it up and you have to
follow it that's a big divide and i
think people across the political aisle
across the partisan lines are sick of
that sort of thing
and on the point of this vaccine by the
way a lot of people don't want to get it
a lot of people don't want to get and i
think they have perfectly good reason
not to and the white house despite
bragging about how so everyone's getting
it and that's where almost at
70 80 90 they clearly
are not hitting those numbers because
the white house
and the ruling class are enlisting pop
culture figures to try to get young
people
to get vaccinated including olivia
rodrigo someone i had never heard of
until yesterday
who showed up to the white house press
briefing to get your kids vaccinated
i have a special guest with me today uh
joining us in the briefing room is
actress and multi-platinum recording
singer songwriter olivia rodrigo who
traversed red lights and stop times to
see us
if you know her music you'll get that
dad jokes there
thing and we just want to thank you for
using your platform and your voice
for elevating the important issue of
young people getting
vaccinated she's here today to meet with
the president and dr
fauci later this afternoon but she
agreed to come say a quick hello to all
of you
first with that i'll turn it over to you
olivia hi
um first i want to say i am beyond
honored and humbled to be here today to
help spread the message
about the importance of youth
vaccination
i'm in awe of the work president biden
and dr fauci have done and was happy to
help lend my support to this important
initiative
all right olivia rodrigo says it's
important for kids to get the vex i
guess
i guess it's true because you see we've
got to follow the science
we've got to listen to the experts and
that means that when a
a parent musician that i've never heard
of tells you to do it then you do it
right that's that's she's the expert
she's
they they are the experts the the ruling
elite not just the scientists but
the people in big business the people in
higher education the people in the media
the people
they're they're all the experts right
cnn it's the experts pop singers they're
the experts too
this sort of thing used to work a lot
better i get i get why biden is doing
this because biden is 100 years old
and he he was coming up in politics
during a time
when there was more of a common culture
so if you could get
the big movie star to come out and
support your political cause that was a
really big deal
if you could get the big pop singer to
come out that was a really big deal
what has changed though is that the the
culture has fractured
part of this was cultural because of the
cultural revolutionaries of the 60s
broke up our common culture
so part of this is the chickens coming
home to roost for the left part of this
is technological there are no longer
just three tv networks it's
a zillion tv networks none of which
anybody watches
a lot of internet channels on a podcast
so that's broken up to
uh because of that practical aspect i
suspect this is not going to have a
great effect i mean
we talk about how difficult the
political situation is right now on this
show
but a glimmer of hope here is that
the the left has is dealing with this
double-edged sword
they upended the common culture during
the 1960s and 70s and they broke the
political consensus and they made
everything political so now who washes
the dishes is political your running
shoes are political your chicken
sandwiches
are political and everything is kind of
divisive
and everything makes a political
statement okay but
the flip side of that is that now that
they're trying to settle that
that culture back down along their own
standards people are still pretty
divided up there's still a lot of
niche audiences out there and i just
don't think people
are buying i don't think olivia rodrigo
is going to
convince people to take an experimental
drug
just because of the strength of her
records or whatever she sells
when you want to be safe i would
strongly recommend you check out
ring i love my little son my cute little
six-month-old bundle of joy
i love him i don't want anything bad to
happen to him okay and it's why
i'm really glad that my wife
and my son can know who is outside of
the door before they
open that door with ring it doesn't
matter if you're in your house
if you're at the office if you're in
another state or another continent
you can see and speak to whoever is at
your door
with ring and it's not just at the
doorstep by the way it's also
every other inch of your house which you
can monitor with ring
you can control it all from your phone
you can install it yourself in minutes
even i can and i'm not exactly the
handiest guy in the world
very very cool technology makes a great
housewarming present
and allows you to know is the delivery
man at the door i'll open it is the
pizza guy at the door i'll open it is my
mother-in-law at the door
don't breathe don't don't say no i'm
joking i'm joking am i
start protecting your home today with
ring alarm go to ring.com knowles to get
your ring alarm security kit today
you can build the system that's right
for your home have it up and running in
minutes go to ring.com knowles
ring.com slash knowles when
the liberal establishment is not trying
to
jab your kids with experimental drugs
the establishment
is trying to mutilate them and when i
say the establishment
on this show because i'm not just
talking about the government
okay i know by the way i don't want to
sound like i'm a conspiracy theorist or
something like it's a
shadowy cabal of people you know
operating in the shadows that's not
what's going on they're operating out in
the open and they're obviously colluding
with one another
when there is a negative news story that
affects the democratic candidate for
president
it's not just the government that's
going to shut that down it's twitter and
facebook and google working on behalf
of the liberal establishment and there
are formal relationships and informal
relationships between
the act of the administrative state and
these big tech companies
but it also involves the media and it
also involves big corporations who will
change their corporate policies to
better accord with deliverance all and
the institutions of higher education and
lower education which are indoctrinating
your kids
into the ideology of the regime they're
all sort of working together
and so one ideology that they're pushing
right now
is transgenderism and they're doing this
not because
a zillion people in this country are men
who are who believe that they're women
or vice versa it's not because the
psychological problem affects that many
people
though there is a social contagion
aspect so it is spreading actually
but they're doing it because if they can
redefine
nature if they can redefine sex itself
that is
the culmination of their
decades actually centuries long
political plan of liberation the
political plan of emancipation
the political plan of redefining nature
i mean this this was
what marx set out and his ideological
air set out explicitly to do
and it's what so many revolutionaries in
the modern era have set out to do
they've set out as whitaker chambers the
ex-communist says
to pursue what the serpent told eve in
the garden of eden
they set out to to pursue the plan of ye
shall be as gods
and so that's why the pronouns are such
a big political fight that's why
transiting the kids is such a big
political fight
so two amazon employees just quit
at least two maybe more because
amazon is continuing to sell my friend
abigail schreier's book
irreversible damage about people who
come to regret
transiting their kids and the kids who
come to regret having their bodies
mutilated by
irresponsible parents and by pervert
public health
officials now
this is good abigail schreier actually
responded to amazon and said you're
welcome
amazon hr department i've just relieved
you of some terrible employees
which is true but i make this point
because we've been having some
discussions
over over the past few days and just
with various friends of mine and
colleagues trying to work through this
issue of of transgenderism
and some people have said look we don't
want to throw bombs we don't want we
don't want to just be needlessly
provocative
and so we shouldn't needlessly call
bruce jenner bruce
bruce that's his dead name he now he's
caitlin and
my response to that would be well
caitlyn is a woman's name and he's not a
woman so he's not caitlyn
will and maybe we shouldn't call him he
maybe we shouldn't call him she because
he's obviously not a woman but we should
avoid pronouns altogether we should we
shouldn't be
we shouldn't just be throwing bombs
now i i think first of all compassion
involves telling people the truth i
don't think lying to people is
particularly compassionate
or kind i think the truth will set you
free and i think lies are actually very
disrespectful
i think that comforting people sometimes
involves a little tough love i'm
reminded of the bio tapestry
the depiction of the battle of hastings
there's a guy with a big club and he's
beating people with it
and it says here bishop odo holding a
club comforts the boys
we don't think about comforting in that
way but he was comforting them he was
saying get back in the fight you guys
he's smacking him with a club sometimes
you need a little a little tough love
even if that means explaining reality in
a way that
might offend people who are living in a
delusion but
even beyond the redefinition of sex and
the pronouns and everything
consider this no one is suggesting that
we call
bruce jenner a pervert no one is
suggesting that we call bruce jenner a
degenerate or language that would really
be quite offensive
we're suggesting that we call bruce
jenner who is a man
by the male pronoun and that is now
considered
provocative that is now considered bomb
throwing
that is now considered red meat to the
base red meat to the base
has been redefined has been so
hollowed out that it now involves
calling a man a man that's the red meat
and no polite person would ever do that
we should be compassionate
that's i think that is evidence in
itself of this
hugely successful process of redefining
all of reality and speaking of
transitioning
we can't just talk about sex we've got
to talk about race
and ilaria baldwin ellaria
baldwin is alec baldwin's wife i guess
she's something of a social media star
herself
his wife got caught pretending to be
spanish
for years and years and years ilaria
baldwin
pretended to be spanish she's not really
illaria she's
hillary she didn't she didn't grow up
with you know exclusively speaking
spanish or anything like that she grew
up in america
and she speaks english she got caught
because people
noticed that her accent would change
depending on what interview she was
giving
so she was on an nbc show and she she
somehow couldn't remember the english
award the for a cucumber
have very few ingredients we have
tomatoes we have
a hottest cucumber cucumbers we have
red pepper okay we have um
what is how you say how you say in
english
oh a cucumber right so okay wow this
woman she doesn't speak english very
well but she's trying that's good but
then
then you hear another interview of her
and her english is is perfectly fine
it's not easy and i think part of it is
that i'm in shape before i have a baby
and then i stay active when i'm pregnant
and that's you know
i'm not trying to stay then i'm just
trying to keep my circulation going and
stretching and keep my muscle tone up
and then when i have the baby i've been
so lucky to have pretty good
labor and delivery so then i can kind of
hit the road right outdoors
so elaria baldwin is like that person
who studies abroad for a semester in
college
in in england for instance and then
comes back and says like well right
there governor
you're going to the pub later tonight
for a point yeah bye hey
i want some more you want some more you
know and i actually i know a person who
did this and it was
it's very strange i mean it is clearly
something has gone a little
a little awry in their psychology there
was a gal that i knew
who she went to london for like a month
or less
and she came back and had the most
preposterous fake british accent
i've ever ever heard and actually a
friend of mine who's from the uk
uh asked he said oh where did you live
in the uk he doesn't have an accent by
the
way
and she said oh you know in london yeah
we're in london well you know like
on the next to the tube or whatever you
know next to the pub
uh so it's it's this is very sad and
embarrassing and uh so
illario baldwin uh you know took her
licks and kind of
you know just tried to disappear for a
little bit so now she's back and she's
saying
that actually she is trans-cultural and
this is perfectly good she's culturally
fluid she says
when you are multi whatever multi
everyone's multi now we all contain
multitudes
it can feel hard to belong you're
constantly going back and forth trying
to be more this or more that you feel
you have to explain
why you are the way you are trying to
fit into a world of labels where there
might not be one that perfectly defines
you you will never quite fit in because
of the other parts of you
shape and influence all your parts we
need to normalize the fact that we're
all unique
our culture our languages sexual
orientations religions political beliefs
are allowed to be fluid no two of us are
completely alive got to be fluid we're
all fluid these days nothing's fixed
nothing's set
you see this reflected in language by
the way people no longer state plain
facts
they no longer say this is true they'll
say i think this is true then it became
i believe this is true then it became i
feel
like this is true because i feel like is
unfalsifiable you can't have an argument
with someone who feels
like because they're not making a truth
claim they're just
talking about their feels man and i know
this seems subtle and
i i some people might say i'm reading
too much into it but i don't think i am
so
michael you're just talking about
semantics well semantics means meaning
right i mean this is this is the premise
of my book speechless
i think this is the most important tool
that has reshaped our culture and these
things really do matter no one wants to
be pinned down on anything
everyone's a pan bi trans fluid whatever
you know nobody nobody is the plain old
thing that they say that they are which
brings me to a
a tweet yesterday from the economist i
don't watch soccer i don't like soccer
very much as i've mentioned on this show
so i didn't follow the i guess it was
the world cup or some big soccer game in
italy won
and the economist tweets out quote the
most striking aspect
of italy's 26-man squad before it took
to the pitch was that
alone among the main contenders it did
not include a single player
considered as being of color even that
phrasing is strange considered
as being what they're saying is there's
no black people on the team
and that's very bad that's that's what
must be racist or something but then i
thought hold on a second
italy italy is not you know a
propositional nation founded on an idea
with where everyone just comes in from
all over
italy is the country of the italians
so the economist says the most striking
aspect of italy's
soccer team is that they were italians
but you know you never see the reverse
the most striking aspect of nigeria's
soccer team
is that it did not include even one
single norwegian
well that would that's not striking that
that would be expected because
it's the nigerian soccer team so they
don't but it's striking it's striking
that the italian soccer team
contains italians because we're all
supposed to be trans and fluid man
no one's supposed to have a nation at
all even even italy it's like
one of the oldest nations you know it's
what it's an it's a nation that was it's
been conquered
and has been has been a little fluid on
its borders over time
but the idea that italy would comprise
italians this is too shocking to people
who don't no one wants to be pinned down
in this culture
things are not going very well in the
west right now as candace will tell you
today
on her show go check out candace you can
subscribe right now to
dailywiredailywire.com use
code candace you'll get 25 off your new
membership candace is going to be
talking about cuba and communism and all
sorts of terrible things also
you can pre-order ben's new book this is
a great book to pre-order after you
order
my book speechless it's great really
it's a great one-two punch
you order speechless you pre-order ben's
book i really like the title of ben's
book
because it will be my campaign slogan
the authoritarian moment
so go check that out and prepare for
knowles 2028 the authoritarian moment
we'll be right back with a lot more
things are not going great for the west
right now
this is true in our political system
crumbling the lockdowns everywhere
a faith in our institutions falling
apart divisiveness across all sorts of
lines
through the roof but especially
you can see it in the population we are
not
having babies and that's a weird thing
it's weird when populations decide
to die and so the united states has been
below replacement
level birth rate for a very long time
now and it keeps dropping steadily which
is part of the reason by the way that
that
the country floods itself with illegal
aliens and
legal immigrants for that matter too is
just to kind of keep keep the country
afloat
while the native population across races
is not not replacing itself
that's bad and then the flip side of
that is people are killing themselves
they're killing themselves by committing
suicide and they're killing themselves
with drugs especially with drugs
in 2020 drug overdose deaths
hit the highest number ever recorded
according to the cdc ever there is a
good i know i know people who
friends of mine died of drug overdose
deaths last year i suspect
many of you out there could say the same
thing
i think a lot of people know people who
have who have dealt with drug problems
especially
during 2020 when everyone was locked
indoors number rose by 30
year over year the drug deaths
skyrocketed
to 93 000 deaths
in 2020 that's an increase from 72 000
in just 2019 and it was already bad
in 2019. you could say right now the
biggest
problem in america is the drug overdose
death
and i don't think it's coincidental that
it happened in 2020. i don't think it's
coincidental that when you locked people
inside for a year
and you told them that they can't see
their families and they can't go to
christmas and they can't
go to their be with their loved ones
while they're dying and they can't have
their weddings and they can't have their
college graduation they can't do
anything that you would see more deaths
of despair you are seeing here
the the culmination of two
really bad arguments that our ruling
elite have been pushing for a long time
the first one is
fairly narrow and it was an argument
made during the early days of the
lockdown which is and andrew cuomo made
it actually which is funny because he
was the worst
worst governor in america on covet quote
as we call him
andrew cuomo said if we can save just
one life
it'll all be worth it to shut down the
entire state of new york it'll all be if
we save just one life okay maybe he
saved one i don't think he did
i think actually his policies are
directly responsible
for the deaths of thousands of senior
citizens which he knew about and covered
up from the federal government that's
actually what i think happened
but even if hypothetically you could say
okay well one
one life was saved from covid because of
the lockdown policies
even if that were true which it is not
how many lives were ended
because of those lockdown policies
leading to deaths of despair
like suicide and especially like drug
overdoses
how many looks like 93 000 people killed
themselves that increase that that
20 21 000 death increase
hard to explain that apart from what was
going on
in the entire society last year with the
lockdowns
you can only if you could only save one
person and kill 21 000 people
it will have been worth it really i
don't think so i mean i think that even
that calculation is pretty crass isn't
it
these these calculations of just
utilitarianism
it's really ugly stuff so i think the if
we can save one life argument
just was preposterous because there's
more to society there's more to human
life
than just staying alive from a virus i
mean
this is actually a problem that trump
had too at trump's coveted press
conferences
the only people he had behind him for
the most part were
public health officials but america
is about more than public health our
government our society is about more
than public health
he should have had the public health not
fouchy you should that guy should have
been exiled to an island somewhere
but some public health guy okay and you
should have had an economic
advisor and you should have had a
military advisor
and you should have had all sorts of
advisors behind him to say okay
well here's the effect on covid
infection rates and here's the effect on
our national security
and here's the effect on our economy and
here's the effect on people's
livelihoods and here's the effect on
this that and the other thing and then i
think we would have had a very different
decision the other argument here
that is that is really too bad on the
drug drug overdose deaths
is an argument that the left has made
for a long time that the right has
bought into and it's one that we've
talked about on the show a lot so we
don't need to go
too much into it but is the it is the
confusion of liberty and licentiousness
the idea that freedom means that i
should be able to do drugs whenever i
want you here a lot of people on the
right calling for the legalization of
drugs
all sorts of drugs you're seeing this
this push go on now in state after state
after state
and it's just a bad idea and it's based
on a preposterous logic
that if you if you legalize all the
drugs
fewer people will do them you can't
legislate morality anyway and you know
you can't
you can't control people's behavior with
or shape people's behavior with the laws
and politics is downstream of culture
whatever
you necessarily legislate morality
that's what all legislation does
if legislation doesn't shape behavior
then it doesn't do anything at all the
entire the exclusive function of
legislation
is to shape behavior to encourage
certain behaviors and discourage other
behaviors
and when you create incentives for some
behaviors
and you punish other behaviors do you
know what happens
you get more of the former and less of
the latter that's that's just the way it
works
you know actually uh because the law it
has all these in inverse relationships
with behavior we need to legalize murder
because then we'll have less murder will
we i don't think we will
i don't think we call me crazy i guess
i'm not an economic expert
i'm not but i'm pretty sure that when
you reward some behavior and you punish
other behavior
you get more of the former and less of
the latter and there is no natural right
to do drugs
it is not good it is not it does not
lead to freedom it leads to slavery and
the right needs to
shake itself out of that very silly idea
otherwise we're all we're going to
become a nation of cuomos
who spout a bunch of preposterous
platitudes and end up
governing ourselves in the worst
possible way
actually on the cuomo aspect on quovid
here
not only does cuomo have the scam he had
the sex scandal which i always felt was
just a democrat distraction so that
people wouldn't talk about his actual
scandal which is about
lying about the number of covet deaths
uh so he was lying about the number of
coveted debts in the nursing homes but
then
turns out he he also very likely was
under counting covid deaths more broadly
so
the irony of this is so so sweet
especially because i saw governor
desantis last night
chris cuomo last year tweeted out
can we trust the data from florida's
governor this is fredo cuomo the one
who's on cnn he said can we trust the
data yeah the data show
that desantis is doing a better job in
florida than
cuomo is doing in new york even though
the media are saying desantis is
doing the worst job on covet and cuomo's
doing the best job on coven he's going
to win emmy awards for it
which makes sense because it was a
fiction that was going going on in new
york
but he says can we trust the data from
florida's governor and it turns out we
can
we can trust the data from florida's
governor he counted the deaths and he
just
is doing a good job on his policies but
it turns out we can't
trust the data from chris cuomo's
brother andrew it turns out that andrew
cuomo in new york
was doing the exact same thing that the
left was
accusing the republican governors of
doing
once more an example of the projection
of the left they do this all the time
they accuse you
of doing what they are brazenly doing
themselves
cuomo's covid death count includes
only laboratory confirmed kovid 19
deaths at hospitals
nursing homes and adult care facilities
now other states
have taken the approach that's more in
line with the cdc
and these states some some are
republican like florida some are
democrat like california
some have unconstitutional election
practices like pennsylvania
some are left-wing like new jersey all
of these different states
have followed the approach that's in
line with what the cdc says to do
which includes in fatality counts all
cases where covet 19 is an associated or
contributing factor
this has been such a broad count that in
some cases it's led to this ridiculous
over counting of covet deaths
where if you have kovit and you don't
even know you have cova then you get
shot in the head
you get counted as a covet death because
you tested positive at your autopsy or
when you when you're brought to the
hospital
so all of these states are doing that
but cuomo because he did such a bad job
in new york
is under counting it speaking of bad
governors
governor nussolini the leader of my
former state
of california is being recalled and the
campaign
has been pretty rough because
the only major nominal republican who's
running against
newsome is bruce jenner
as caitlyn who says that he's no loyalty
to the republican party
and the only thing he really cares about
is lgbt issues with an emphasis on
transgenderism so you think well hold on
the the republican candidate is somehow
worse than the sitting democrat he's a
terrible governor but he's somehow worse
because at least with newsom you know
what you're getting
with bruce jenner he's saying he's a
republican but then he's saying he's not
a republican he's saying all he cares
about is transgenderism which is very
much the opposite
of the sort of policy republicans want
to pursue well now there's some hope
because a friend of mine has announced
he's running for governor
the sage from south central larry elder
who just
last week announced his run we have
rising crime
ridiculous laws that allow a person to
steal up to 950
a day without being a felon without
fearing going to jail
we have an attack on the police calling
the police to pull back
we have incredible homelessness here in
california it is estimated that maybe
one quarter of all the homeless
population
in the in america is here in california
and why not
we're not dealing with the underlying
problem we're throwing money after money
after money building homes
and attracting other people who get free
homes without dealing with the
underlying problems
and maybe just maybe i can do something
about that so i am hereby
announcing that i am running for
governor of california
in this recall election to be held on
september 14th if you want to help
please go to my website elect elder dot
com
that's elect elder dot com i cannot do
it
without a great deal of money because my
opponent gavin newsom
has no spending limits i do he doesn't
so this is really great news i think for
republicans
in california because there there are
other candidates
in in california who are running who i
think could be perfectly
decent governors i'm thinking of kevin
falconer down in in san diego
seems like a fairly conservative guy i
think he's running for governor
but the problem is he doesn't have very
high name identification he's not not
doing great in terms of fundraising
so it doesn't matter he could be the
second coming of
coolidge or churchill or reagan or
washington all combined and
nevertheless it would be a very uphill
battle especially because no other
democrats are running
in the race uh so newsom newsome doesn't
really face any challenges in that
regard
uh but he doesn't have that name idea
and i think larry elder does i mean
larry's been on the radio for a long
time
he goes on tv quite a lot he
i agree with him on a great many things
he's probably a little more libertarian
than my views you know he's not not
quite to the right of attila the hun
but he's good he's a good guy he'd be he
would be a good governor and i am
glad that now there is an alternative to
bruce jenner i think the embrace of
bruce jenner
is is just the death of the republican
party in california it's just pathetic
if we can't
the gop i get it in california or new
york also my home state
new york i know that they've had to make
compromises to be in any way electorally
viable even in some local races and i
understand that's a political reality
that republicans have to deal with there
if we as republicans cannot even stand
up
for the difference between men and women
if we cannot stand up and conserve the
ladies room from men
entering into it we're not conserving
anything
and the as far as i can tell the only
thing we would get out of a bruce jenner
governorship
is a a misguided sense of owning the
libs by adopting their most
sacred metaphysical premises which
doesn't seem like totally owning the
libs to me
all you'll hear you're actually hearing
this now from some prominent republicans
they're saying
you know democrats are the real
transphobes what what is that even i
don't even i don't think that word means
anything
why now we're adopting that kind of
language i'm really glad great to see
that larry elder is running for governor
wish him the best of luck in his
campaign
i hope that he can raise some money i
hope that he can really mount a
challenge because
he he if he just went in there and just
cleaned up the crime
and fixed the budget even slightly that
would be such
great news for california there are a
lot of republicans and there are a lot
of conservatives and there are a lot of
disaffected liberals in california
this is how gavin newsom got recalled in
the first place
and so i certainly wish larry the best
of luck because at the federal level
right now
the federal government is really really
clamping down on right wingers and i
think that
the advances we're going to make in the
near future are going to be at the state
level
the federal government right now is
spending 6.1 million dollars
on just a database just an evidence
database to prosecute
the capital rioters you know the the
participants in the insurrection
the coup d'etat the greatest threat to
our republic
since world war ii
since pearl harbor since 9 11. seriously
people
on the left prominent leftists have made
that comparison
between september 11th between planes
flying into the twin towers and the
pentagon
and the guy in the horn helmet dancing
around the capitol
they've compared those two things i'm
not saying the federal government's
spending 6.1 million dollars to
prosecute them they're going to spend a
lot more than i'm saying they're
spending 6.1 million dollars
on just the evidence
now you might say michael i think what
happened at the capitol is ugly it's bad
i don't like it
i don't want that to happen in our
country it was ill-advised it was
wrong as a matter of justice and also
wrong as a matter of tactics okay
sure yeah right i'm not making any
comment on that
i'm pointing out that horn guy danced
around the capitol
and smiley guy took nancy pelosi's
lectern
and the only person who was killed in
the violence of that day
was a trump supporter named ashley
babbitt
killed by a police officer despite all
the lies told to us by the new york
times and washington post which they
later had to retract about
trump rioters attacking police officers
i'm pointing out that for six to eight
months
blm and antifa burned down the country
and killed a lot of people and
destroyed a lot of property and stole a
lot of property and they're largely
getting off the hook
and there's no 6.1 million dollar
database and there's no massive law
enforcement campaign
to hold these people responsible and in
in a lot of cases they're getting plea
deals to plead way way down
and avoid jail time in some cases the
charges are just being dropped entirely
or not even brought in the first place
this
is an unacceptable double standard
and it's it's really as we've pointed
out before it's hierarchy it's saying
that when the democrats riot it's good
and when republicans riot it's
it's the worst thing in the world even
when the democrat riots are by every
measure
much much worse
according to the ruling liberal elite
the conservatives are the big problem
that we the country hasn't been this
divided since the civil war in the gop
they're the confederates
the assault on free and fair elections
is just such a threat
literally i've said it before
we're facing the most significant test
of our democracy
since the civil war that's not hyperbole
since the civil war
the confederates back then never
breached the capital
as insurrectionists did on january the
6th
i'm not saying this alarm you i'm saying
this because you
should be alarmed so
i'll make the point i don't want to harp
on it but it is
it's an irony so i have to point it out
that
the confederates were all democrats and
the union were all republicans
the parties did not switch as the left
insists
that they did but of course political
parties change and they evolve and so
you know there's it's not a direct
analog i don't
you know i don't want to just retreat to
that typical republican talking point of
you know
democrats haven't been this angry since
we freed their slaves or whatever yeah
i get political parties do change over
time and so i i think that's a little
bit of a cheap shot
though it is ironic and one has to point
it out but notice
no here here is a real comparison
between the democrats and the
confederates
the confederates seceded the
confederates wanted the war the
confederates
i mean that that is that was the the
very essence of secession is saying we
are no longer a country
and they hoped that the north would just
let them go and that that doesn't happen
in a country you can't just secede from
a country
the logic of a country does not permit
you to do that
okay who's talking about the civil war
right now i know some people on the
right ask questions about this are we
headed for a civil war so much political
violence are we
but i'm talking about at the top level
of politics who's talking about civil
war
is it donald trump no is it
ron desantis no is it ted cruz no is it
josh hawley no
it's the democrats it's joe biden
it's other people hillary clinton saying
you can't be civil with your opponents
it's maxine waters saying go become
violent with republicans
it's it's kamala harris bailing out
leftist rioters who were committing
violence against their political
opponents
among other people they're the ones
talking about civil war
they're the ones calling for violence
against
against conservatives and yet because
they control all the organs of
communication
they say that it's it's us they're
gaslighting it's projection it's exactly
the opposite of reality and the regime
is backing them up
the regime the broad the blob the
establishment
the ruling class is backing them up
kevin mccarthy
who's the house gop leader he tweeted
the other day
about how inflation is really spiking
and this
and he's tying this to joe biden's
policies which is
certainly fair but it's just just a
tweet about inflation
twitter slapped a sensitive content
label on that
not a call to violence arms insurrection
no just pointing out that inflation is
spiking because of joe biden's stupid
economic policies
sensitive content that is big tech
which controls the flow of information
around the internet controls speech in a
republic meaning it controls politics
doing the bidding of the dominant
liberal regime
sensitive content
there's a video i'm not even going to
play the video there's a video going
around right now from cuba
of of the government shooting a man
they're they're now killing the
protesters in the street shooting a man
in front of a toddler
and this follows the threat from the
dictator of cuba miguel diaz-canel who
said we will do anything to preserve the
quote-unquote revolution to preserve the
ruling regime we will do anything
it's a very nearly explicit call for
violence and then he backed it up with
violence
miguel diaz-canel is still on twitter
the dictator of cuba who is
killing his own people now still on
still on twitter donald trump
was booted off of twitter after telling
his
followers to be peaceful remember be
peaceful don't be violent be peaceful
you're getting kicked off twitter mr
president for for inspiring violence
miguel diaz-canel saying we will do
anything and go to all measures possible
to preserve the regime
he's still on twitter because it's not
about a principle and it's not about
violence and it's not about
preserving our democracy or anything
like that it's preserving
the dominant liberal regime that's
that's what this is
that's the divide here and so we say
save us florida man
florida man you're our hope please save
us florida and really
help us out any republican who will
channel that who understands what
desantis in particular
is recognizing right now but i think the
majority
of ordinary americans are recognizing
too that's the divide and we've got to
defend the people and we've got to
defend the constitution
against a technocratic elite that wants
to undermine
both of those things i'm michael knows
this michael knowles shall see tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show blm proves once again
it is a garbage communist organization
we'll talk all about it that's today on
the benchmark show give it a listen